the titanic
was really a cover for a highly
classified
military operation to investigate
two nuclear submarines that we lost
during the cold war with all hands the
uss thresher
and the uss scorpio they ironically
turned out to be
on either side of where the titanic was
lost
and quite honestly had that not been the
case you wouldn't be
looking at the guy that found the
titanic the navy wanted complete
100 photo documentation of both
rec sites and to answer some questions
what are the nuclear reactors doing
what's the status of the nuclear weapons
is there any evidence
soviets have been there well i said
to both the secretary of the navy john
layman and admiral thundeman who was my
boss as a naval officer
what if we use the titanic as
the cover i thought it was a cockamamie
story i mean
find the titanic and i said well it'd be
great cover wouldn't it
finally said thumbs up i told them do
whatever you want just don't spend any
more money
boy did i work faster we pretty well
knew what happened to the thresher we
mapped her a year earlier
they knew very little about the scorpion
it took me about a week to get there and
map it
we mapped it extensively and there was
no
evidence of human remains i mean that
would have been tough
but no the reactors were intact
so that was good news there were no
other indications of
something amiss other than the submarine
had gone down and it had imploded
as soon as the navy was satisfied we
headed northwest for the titanic
i had 12 days to hunt but
i had learned something from the
thresher and scorpion that i couldn't
tell anyone
because both submarines imploded
before they came to the bottom so on
their way down
the pressure hulls went and that
implosive event is a gigantic explosion
and it just blew the submarines apart
but when i was mapping it we realized
that
the heavy stuff went down like a bowling
ball
reactors boom but then the lighter stuff
was a
big long line and i went didn't the
titanic do the same thing
so let's not look for the big pieces of
titanic
because they're only that big let's look
for the debris
which meant i could space my search
lines much
wider apart but titanic did not lie
where she was thought to be
days of feudal search dragged on
how close were you to failure
well i had i was reaching the point of
where i thought
we'd failed and if i thought we had
and i was going i went back to my room
and
we had the watch going it was a
mid-watch everything happens
on the midnight watch 12 to 4. i don't
know why
everything important occurs right around
midnight
wreckage bingo
somebody out here and i went in and
there it was the
i mean the boiler was on the screen oh i
love it i love it
this sucker exists okay
we were jumping up and down we were
patting one another on the back and then
someone
looked at the clock in the command
center
and said she sinks in 20 minutes it was
two in the morning
she sank at 2 20. and that
innocent comment just grounded us
and we realized you have finally
put the rest where these souls were lost
and everyone filed out and it was a
moment of silence
because we were there and that was
pretty
pretty powerful
[Music]
you